hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hello hello an RPG horror
game that I actually don't know anything
about so that's not really much of a
surprise but I honestly do not know much
about it because it was not much
description and there was only one
screenshot to accompany it so I really
don't know what I'm getting myself into
but you guys have been asking for
another RPG horror game for a long time
now and I'm eager to deliver so let's go
yay oh this is a screenshot I saw hello
I seem to be a girl or a boy I can't
exactly tell do I have an inventory no I
do not so what's going on here a
fireplace rare these days isn't this
your house or did you burn into
something burning there's something
banging to burn break into something
that you don't know and someplace you
don't want to go hi hi friend how you
doing okay why were you there why do you
well okay I'm confused already did I
actually have a clock in here well I
don't know you seem far too drunk to
actually remember what happened in your
wall hi hello other friend hi are you my
roommate are you my other friendly
neighbor that's just gonna keep waving
at me can I do it go oh hi whoa whoa hey
well now I didn't the way what oh no
come on what are you doing to me you're
just gonna end the game there what the
hell I don't even get a chance what the
hell is this this is baloney Wow okay
thank you now there's a who's breathing
over there or is it over there by that
wall that I'm pointing at oh hi wait a
minute that letter can wait there seems
to be okay what the hell what the hell
is going on in this game
dot dot dot hello-o
all right then
shut up Poochie I wanna talk to you
right now don't do it
what was that someone freeze frame on
that I didn't know what it was
hello Akari okay so so what about that
oh come on that was the first ending I
didn't oh god damn it I saw a girl in
her underwear you're just gonna play
whoa hey hey what hey whoa whoa whoa
what's going on we no no no no no there
was a letter on the ground there there
was a ladder why was there a ladder log
glug-glug ah come on boy that's not
helpful at all I didn't even get another
word all right then this game is a
little strange I don't know exactly what
I'm supposed to be doing here oh just go
into bed I guess and I get another
ending just let it be morning this is
not exactly what I was hoping to get
myself into what is going on in this
game here why did I start in the bed hey
I remember that breaking maybe I could
still lick some off the floor what a
waste of good wine you would know
everyone knows that this is the
authentic Japanese huh stop it I don't
want to answer your damn phone
it reflects the room had already I how
you doing hi oh yeah you're good good to
see can I get up there with this chair
the curtains are drawn good feels like
it would be risky to turn it on now why
how can I ask what you mean what
happened I didn't say I'm looking I was
complaining to the webcam that's me ow
what happened why did I why was that a
painful end all I did was blow out the
candles
oh so my Peter blow skills are not
welcome in here I see answer the phone
how about no how about I don't do that
I'll just get the same ending a Gotham
that's ultima phone I don't know what
the hell that is but that is okay wait a
minute you were gonna kill me don't even
try it I'm far too agile and/or handsome
to be defeated by the likes of you you
know do you have anything else to say no
shut up Poochie no nice to hear your
sass right now god damn it's gonna be
the same painful ending isn't it that
doesn't sound painful approaching
footsteps Oh buster new yet my god it's
brilliant time probably yelled a little
bit too loud there I apologized to no
one I'm gonna answer the phone
preemptively a smartphone I don't use it
much anymore
what are you too hipster for it are you
one of those people with god damn and
I'm gonna do the same damn anything I
did before oh shut up and 23 with a
hangover how am I supposed to know what
anything have already gotten how am I
supposed to know anything about this
game cuz I actually don't good yeah I
don't even try it
yeah huh what happened here oh I don't
know I think I got a lake test out like
every single panel here maybe
something's gonna happen up over here
god there's got to be some sort of a
secret I'm missing cuz if I've gotten
all the way up to ending 30 so I'm just
gonna assume that there are other
endings all the way up until that point
so uh hi there friend what's up my
yellow-bellied you gonna show me other
secrets to get out of here thunk did I
just break it feels almost alive what is
it over there I can't see it Barry zoom
in on that
so can't make it out what the hell is it
okay blood sticks to the mirror well
blood is want to do that so okay what do
I do
what the hell am I supposed to do there
isn't any instructions here is this all
the game is can I sit in this chair and
slowly away my death not in the mood to
read everyone should be in the mood to
read not in the mood to read not in the
mood raid 9:00 the motor raid okay
you're still high wait a minute here
doll you try to sass me a young man the
chair is obviously telling me that I am
indeed in the mood to read
not the mood to be to blow those candles
anymore it's her again
he's life hey ray
hell yeah indeed I don't know sorry I'm
sorry everybody my behavior is abhorrent
shut the F up I'm gonna answer it again
because the name of the game is hello
yeah yeah whatever I drop my wine hello
this is a car he isn't it answer please
oh maybe I'm supposed to answer the
phone over and over and that's what's
gonna ho
oh no no reply
hey where are you um in my apartment
recording a video ho ho hi well
something has changed in this room hello
it feels almost alive where what could
be wrong with a teddy bear the zoo's to
live there's no possible way he could
become a salmon I keep dropping my wine
some nail and hold my bottle they'll
hold my liquor if you know what I mean
even though bottle bottle wine isn't
actually hey wait a minute I saw that
move you can't tell me I did not cuz I
did why did they fall down souvenirs
from my girlfriend oh hey wait a minute
things are moving here and they should
not be moved
oh it's good right oh it doesn't gommi I
thought I was actually gonna kill me
that may have been another ending I do
not know what the hell is going on here
I dropped my wine cart Alice huh it's
gonna be painful is you're gonna be
footsteps oh god damn it's the
approaching footsteps again well he's
hardly doing any good I thought that it
was gonna be a bit different because
there was another area little was it
loaded into the green car vet need to
answer the phone uh hi
dost Eagle girl I saw you I don't hate I
don't hate you I don't hate you anybody
out there I don't hate this game even
though stick it with me oh wait a minute
I saw that move goddamn it why is it
always moving when I think it's not
gonna move
Tacey feet I'll eat it probably not
poison probably not
let me out from the inside I died of
death from poisoning from death
poisoning that death poisoning Goya show
us something what happens if I don't eat
it the Borbon and a wolf Karl wolf job
Mary don't put a wolf job in no one
wants to know what the wolf job is it
reflects our home and I saw that move so
I'm gonna assume that's gonna do the
same damn thing it's done before I just
got to wander around the room hoping and
praying that there's gonna be some sort
of a phone call got down you're a
beautiful lady but I mean I'm a little
bit busier if you could just move your
naked body somewhere away it's a family
friendly Channel we do not much
appreciate that kind of behavior around
here young lady ma'am
preferably not that young bill because
that would be weird don't leave the room
wow I got two things okay
we're gonna do that again ha ha ha you
lost your head over there didn't ya yes
son of a [ __ ] ain't ya can't stay in
this room I know I've already gotten
ended 1 2 and 30 and 18 that's all the
ones I know something with all its dead
no I killed it oh no I'm so sad yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I know I know
hello no but ok please hmm
unseen force ok what kind of scene force
hello where are you wait wait for what
wait for me baby ho no my pot of wine
what ha
ok lady you can back up a little bit
there oh right ok
oh so bad seven happening I'm gonna go
see what happened to the TV first okay
well then why is there a barrel in the
room excellent question
good inquisitive skills don't mind that
it just sent Oh her what the hell is
going on here I go yes
hi barrel how you doing good old
friendly neighborhood barrel the let me
just write lady her you shut the hell up
game now are you distinctly starting to
freak me out I don't like to be freaky
Hikari what do you want from me
what do you want from me baby hey dude
dude new gun
ah I'm suddenly in the mood to read
raining is so much fun
in two days it'll be six years of dating
Kazuki I decide I'll make his favorite
meal I'm sure he'll love it and I have a
very deep voice for a little girl Kazuki
said he has an important business trip
tomorrow and I was already all done
shopping I can't even give him my
present will today make six years Kazuki
I know work is rough I was too harsh on
the phone yesterday
I'm sorry Kazuki called to say he'll be
back tomorrow it feels like it's been so
long I'd better meet a mething actually
this kind of sad I should take this
seriously the entry ends there oh never
mind I could have been silly for like
two more seconds I'm sorry Akari peace I
don't know what Akari did well I'm
guessing that Akari is dead and Kazuki
did some bad stuff ignoring her yeah
sweethearts diary doesn't sound like it
was too happy fun times for you guys oh
god now the room is blue I hate the
color blue it's my least favorite color
a black yet all fifty shades go ahead I
like stretchy shades of black I didn't
like the room of black hopefully the
other one will come back a little better
hello
whoa hey where are you wait for me I
know baby I'll wait for you in the NAFTA
life you seem to be haunting me a little
bit and I don't exactly care for it
oh ho that is a different sound on there
hey what's on TV
so uh that didn't work out for me I'm
trying to get all the endings so I'm
gonna try to get all the secret e stuff
before I actually move on anything else
come on out you little dummy okay
geez all right curtains are drawn what I
didn't do anything there was a face in
the mirror house I supposed to see it
this game window is tiny yeah whatever I
know maybe I'll just go to bed
I don't feel too bad about this I'll
clean up all the blood and entrails and
dead BOTS
yeah all right Oh what do you want from
me Akari also that mirror let kill me
before is staring at me I'll come to
meet you tomorrow
oh I'll dress in my best and I'll get my
best crack of Oh
polkadot condoms maybe not
I'm coming JEP shut up shut up should I
should I be to blow now is that my cue
is that my big kill later Laura well
this should be a oh I didn't I don't
think I got all the endings I'm not
ready no thank you
I'll just wander over here where things
aren't gonna kill me maybe they are oh
good who's getting cold in here I'm glad
that blow fire that blew fires oddly
illuminating raid oh good I got a solid
okay I guess I'll answer the door do Oh
Oh Gary hi already good
well hello my beautiful bride Akari your
skin is such a lovely shade of lair I
scold you how dare you haunt me Akari
I'm not dead not yet I'm alive I have a
future I love you won't you put your
soul to rest that's not very good
scolding you need to really learn okay
lady let's get one thing straight
this blue it's ugly that dress oh oh uh
beautiful baton poor communicator no
okay good I was about to say that ended
it like totally and completely out of
them very unhappy about that
hang on a one second I got stuff to do I
got things to see baby you'll get yours
in a little bit
let me just stare into the mirror to
make sure that I'm gussied up for you
was that another ending do what I get
another ending I don't know if that was
a completely different ending than the
other ones what about this book here
flowers
decorative very whatever hi lady
come on in I love you I'll join you in
the afterlife whether I like it or not
apparently oh no it's my blushing bride
Akari I hug you I embrace you and your
blindness come here my seaton my mama on
a girl oh I won't let you be alone I'll
do whatever I can i girl I'm I had this
guy with long hair can't exactly tell
here but God your face is a little bit
creepy
just put a bag on your head it'll be
great mmm really maybe I don't know
maybe this is a mistake yeah really
really yeah yeah really really I'm glad
oh that's adorable
she was the girl with the butt
it was a but girl she was a girl in the
mirror with a but I think it was because
she had blonde hair surprising I wasn't
just looking at about I've passed on who
know I meant to explore the room a
little bit more
ah dingus dang it damn it I didn't get
all the way to the end that I thought I
was gonna get but that was really cool I
really liked that that was totally
different from all the other ending or
games that are not in the order RPG
[ __ ] games that I played in the past
that was really well made so integrate a
lot of choices to it I really like that
that was well done I know it's been a
while since I did an RPG horror game and
I'm sorry for that guys I've been
meaning to get back into him so I really
hope you enjoyed this one and I want to
do something different for the next in
the RPG horror game that I play I want
you guys to help me decide which one I
play so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
put up two little picture thingies one
of them's got every for me sale or one
of them's gonna be for corpse party so
what will happen is if you want me to
play me sound next click the annotation
on the left the one down here below me
if you want me to play corpse party next
click the one on the left no god damn it
I didn't do it click your left my your
right Misao over it you'll figure it out
there's two annotations click those I'll
know which ones you clicked I'll count
them up whoever gets the most votes that
is the next game I play and I will play
it very shortly here guys I know you
guys have been dying for another RPG
[ __ ]
so let me know what you think thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
so much for clicking the annotations and
helping me vote and as always I will say
oh in the next video bye bye
yeah
what the hell and bounced off the rib